vous savez qu'il ya une grande de
réunion qui se déroule à madrid
actuellement c'est la coop 25 donc les
dirigeants du monde qui tente de trouver
des solutions à la crise climatique mais
regardez ces images là elle circule un
peu partout où sont les effets
impressionnants vous en conviendrez au
groenland des effets des changements
climatiques on en parle avec renault ces
300 secondes de sciences bonjour une
reculade et donc ce sont des lacs qui
s'évapore qui rétrécissent à vue d'oeil
oui bah en fait c'est un phénomène qui
est assez impressionnant qui se passe
sur les calottes glaciaires ont peu
partout à travers le monde mais qu'on
étudie beaucoup groenland donc chaque
été il va y avoir la formation à cause
de l'augmentation des températures
mondiales il va y avoir la formation de
d'énormes lac temporaire à la surface du
glacier un peu partout c'est ce qu'on
voyait à l'écran il ya quelques instants
et souvent c'est la khl avons juste
rester là jusqu'à l'hiver ils ont
rejoint les mets en a beaucoup qui tous
avec toute cette eau la louve a
travaillé la glace à grandir certaines
failles et ensuite l'eau va plonger
jusqu'à la base du glacier et ses lacs
l'avons ce drainé très rapidement et
cette eau là une fois qu'elle est rendue
au dessus du glacis ça va contribuer à
accélérer sa fonte et ça c'est un
phénomène qu'on sait qu'ils existent
depuis un petit moment mais on n'a
jamais été grave vraiment de le voir
fallait au bon endroit au bon moment
mais c'est justement cette semaine il ya
des chercheurs qui ont eu cette
chance-là onu des images de drones qui
ont été publiés par des chercheurs qui
ont vu ce en juillet 2018 des chercheurs
de l'université de cambridge
on devrait avoir ce lac là à l'écran
bientôt c'est des chercheurs qui ont
réussi à montrer que dans un lac et ont
montré un excellent accueil a montré
qu'en 5 heures ce la khl a perdu 5
millions de litres d'eau le lac c'est
vraiment rétrécit d'un coup et tout cela
sous les glaces outre l'eau s'est
engouffrée on va le voir ici c'est la
cave un et cinq ans plus tard on voit
ici le volume de l'eau qui a
complètement disparu et 7,7 aulas a
plongé jusque en dessous du glacier on
parle d'un kilomètre d'épaisseur de
glace est allé assez loin
et une fois qu'ils à cet endroit là tout
cet ouvrage est un peu comme un
lubrifiant parce qu'un glacier c'est une
masse de glace qui avancent vers l'océan
mais ces toiles doubler la vitesse de
progression du glacis en plus à le
soulever d'environ un demi mètre et l'on
parle d'un kilomètre d'épaisseur de
glace donc on imagine toute la force que
cette eau là avait hélas les chercheurs
disent que c'est vraiment important
qu'on étudie davantage ce genre de faits
de là qui apparaît c'est qui ce drame
sous l'eau parce que ça pourrait
vraiment accélérer la vitesse de la
fonte des glaces est donc mené à une
hausse plus rapide du niveau de la mer
dans les impacts
vraiment vraiment tout un tabac sur des
villes côtières peu partout à travers le
monde de ce genre de choses qu'il
faudrait utiliser bientôt aux sujets
dont vous voulez nous parler ce matin on
en avait glissé un mot l'an dernier ça
avait scandalisé la planète ça les bébés
génétiquement modifiés en chine
il était sonné on a des nouvelles web
ainsi ont ceci on se rappelle si une
église ou une histoire qui remonte à
novembre décembre de l'an dernier c'est
un chercheur chinois qui s'appelle ridge
en cui qui avait annoncé la naissance de
jumelles on les connaissait seulement
sous le pseudonyme lui louer nana et si
j'ai le quand elles sont nées ben quand
il était à l'état d'embryon avant leur
naissance de chercher à leur retirer un
gène que le virus du vih non maman utile
y exploite pour infecter des cellules
immunitaires et l'enfant sur le
chercheur disait je vais rentrer enfants
leur résistantes au vih avis le problème
c'est que la méthode utilisée est pas
prêt de près tout ça est pas prête pour
être employé chez des êtres humains les
chartreux le monde les scientifiques
disent que c'est dangereux ils sont
fâchés
ce chercheur a perdu son emploi en chine
mais depuis on n'a pas de nouvelles ils
n'y a pas on sais pas qu'est ce qui
s'est passé exactement on connaît pas
l'état de santé de ses deux enfants là
sont jusqu'à cette semaine où il ya des
journalistes du hématite technology
review qui ont réussi à mettre la main
sur les données originales de chercheurs
là les données que le chercheur voulait
publier au journal nature mécanique j'ai
refusé et s'est donné leur montrer que
non seulement ils n'ont rien que
chercheur fait qui a fonctionné mais en
plus ce que c'était extrait extrêmement
dangereux ces méthodes qui employés donc
non seulement c'est un échec non plus
elle fait dangereux oui pour les bébés
on l'aimé bien c'est sûr d'en face qui
est ce que les données ont montré ces
trois jeux c'est d'abord se montrer que
l'expérience était faite de façon
aucunement éthiques les parents de ses
deux jumelles ont probablement été
manipulée que pour être embarqué dans
l'expérience parce que voulait
désespérément avoir la fécondation in
vitro
il n'y avait pas accès et le chercheur
prenant profiter de ce désespoir là pour
les embarquer dans son dans sa recherche
en plus ils ont montré que les
modifications génétiques que le
cherchant voulais faire ça n'a pas
fonctionné il ya eu des modifications
mais sont plus résistantes au vih que
n'importe qui d'autre
et en plus il y au ca une confirmation
que plein d'autres modifications
génétiques aléatoires qui n'était pas
prévu et ces modifications le peuvent
avoir des effets extrêmement dangereux
pour la santé de ses 12 enfants locke
qui est des effets que des modifications
des problèmes qu'ils n'auraient pas eu
plus tard dans leur vie six
modifications génétiques l'avait pas eu
lieu
donc tout ça ça vient peut confirmer les
craintes que la communauté scientifique
avait l'an dernier et ça montre qu'on
n'est pas prêt vraiment faire ce genre
de modifications avec ces outils
imparfait il ya des enfants donc ils
vont vivre avec ça pour les points 106
enfants l'ont toujours pas de nouvelles
d'eux n'ont jamais eu d'image on sait
pas où est ce qu'à son saut ça reste un
mystère assez grave en ce moment bon on
va alléger le tout il a fait de votre
crâne et que renault allait les images
qui nous met dans l'esprit des fêtes
même équipe et pas mal notre curiosité
qui nous aident à faire ici les ordinale
que vous comptez ici danser aussi
branché dans le mur à l'aquarium du
tennessee ont les aux branchies sur une
anguille électrique donc ceci oui c'est
une démonstration qui était fait je m'en
l'aquarium du tennessee pour montrer
toute l'électricité qu'avait dans cet
animal c'est donc là elle s'appelle on
le voit qui brille de façon
intermittente en fonction des décharges
de langui quand elle a faim ou quand tu
es fâché il ya un petit truc quand même
le dans le fond il ainsi pas directement
branché sur l'anguille des capteurs à
l'intérêt de l'aquarium qui capte ces
décharges et qui retransmettent en temps
réel l'équivalent au sapin mais ces
animaux là serait quand même capable
d'alimenter sont les brochettes
directement l'arbre de noël parce que
les plus grosse anguille peuvent émettre
jusqu'à 850 volts de décharge quand
elles sont fâchés ce c'est assez pour
allumer beaucoup dit beaucoup de
lumières de noël
ok c'est fâcheux trop non on va pas la
fâcher les musiques des images assez
drôle qui ont circulé sur internet c'est
oui et on les a montrés d'ailleurs rdi
matin nos collègues puissent était
sceptique c'est vraiment ça peut mais il
ya un petit transfert qui se fait le
point pour brancher directement dans
l'arbre merci de l'explication